let's get into lordstown motors q1
revenue 2020 with zero
and their net loss was 125 million their
market cap peaked around 5 billion in
september 2020 they're now at 1.5
billion after the doj
news i would think this is going to zero
or be sold for scrap
i could see the 5 billion going down to
50 million in scrap in other words you
lose
you know 90 99 percent of your value as
an
investor and i think the equity holders
could get wiped out completely because
there could be debt and lawsuits etc
they were founded in 2018 by somebody
named steve burns who was the
former ceo of an electric vehicle
manufacturing company workhorse group
that i've never heard of
uh in november of 2019 lordstown became
the owner of a former gm plant in
lordstown
ohio after signing a sales agreement
with the automaker a lot of these
automakers have done this
in fact elon's um fremont i think was a
former toyota plant so these plants
trade hands uh just like
stadiums do or or buildings do gm loaned
lordstown motors 40 million in order to
underwrite
a substantial part of the plant purchase
so that already is a red flag
okay so gm wants to get this plant off
their books
and they give this new company 40
million dollars
in order to do it or underwrites a loan
to do it major red flag feels like
self-dealing
doesn't mean gm's in the wrong but it
doesn't come from a position of strength
and in total gm invested about 75
million into lordstown motors
and joined its board so those would be
to
uh somebody watching the spat go public
somebody thinking about buying into it
oh gm's involved
well are they really involved and
what is 75 million if they're taking
this plan off their hands you net out
the 40 million
okay there's another 35 million sitting
there what exactly is going on here well
in march
uh of 2020 according to the ohio
business journal daily
uh we always like to give credit to the
journalists who
we mention here and who give us the data
uh with these news stories that i do the
analysis on
in march 2020 lordstown motors paid
workhorse group 12 million dollars
for the licensing rights the
intellectual property of the workhorse
w15 pickup truck
wait a second so the ceo's new company
bought the rights from the old company
okay that's self-dealing it's weird
it's only for 12 million maybe you could
explain it away
or maybe it's a red flag right so these
things start to pile up
it kind of reminds me of what we saw
with wework and the self dealing there
remember
adam newman was buying buildings and
then leasing them back to wework or he
claimed he owned the wework ip and
domain name
or the brand and he was leasing it back
to the company
people who do this kind of self-dealing
are typically
not visionary people they're nickel and
diming people who are trying to hustle
other people
it is really really bad form to do this
remember workhorse group ceo was steve
burns and that's his previous company so
this is self-dealing
and yeah you know you could sit it out
but
anytime you have to explain yourself and
things go wrong
that's when there's a problem now if we
work went public and became worth a
hundred billion dollars
you know the the adam newman behavior
would have been like okay that was weird
but we all made money so it's forgivable
right so keep that in mind
when you do something that has the
appearance of impropriety like
sometimes a founder will want to give
themselves more shares in their own
company
well if everybody makes a ton of money
it didn't feel that bad that the founder
awarded themselves five percent more of
the company and the board approved it
because we all got rich but if the
company gets sold and the founder gave
themselves
50 more of the company or whatever it is
that's when you start to have problems
so be very careful as leaders out there
who are listening
the appearance of impropriety is
impropriety
that's what i learned early early in my
career from dave johnson who was my
first boss at sony
music uh he was the general counsel a
great boss
and so uh as part of the business deal
workhorse group was given 10
equity stake in lordstown so then does
steve burns still own lordstown i mean
it just becomes so much self-dealing
that you have to wonder what are these
people thinking in august of 2020
lordstown announced they were merging
with the spak
diamond peak holdings their shares
peaked at 29
to share a 5 billion dollar market cap
they officially listed as dollar sign
ride that's a great ticker symbol in
october 2020.
fast forward to march one short sellers
hindenburg research
hindenburg research the same people who
covered nikola
these are very serious it's a small firm
i talked to the guy on the phone once i
don't know much about them
but i can tell you when they get their
hooks into something you know meat is on
the menu
like these these guys know how to chum
the water these are the big
these are the big sharks uh they may be
a small firm but
man they take a big bite out of
companies when they release a report and
they released a report the lordstown
motors mirage
fake orders undisclosed production
hurdles and
a prototype inferno in the report they
claim that lordstown had misled
investors on both its demand and
production capabilities
the company has consistently pointed to
its book of a hundred thousand
pre-orders as proof of deep demand
for its proposed ev truck our
conversations with former employees
business partners and an extensive
document review show the company's
orders are largely fictitious
and used as a prop to raise capital and
confer
legitimacy let that sink in for example
i'm quoting again from the hindenburg
report
lordstown recently announced a 14 000
truck deal
from e-squared energy supposedly
representing 735 million in sales
e-squared is based out of a small
residential apartment in texas
that does not operate a vehicle fleet
what
i mean literally sometimes journalists
just write these stories and they never
knock on the door or they never look
into the company and then
somebody like hindenburg research even
though they have the term research
they're actually investors and i think
in this case
they're shorting the company therefore
man if
if they find any kind of fraud they're
going to put it out there now
there is a debate to be had here about
using the technique of fear uncertainty
and doubt
fudd to try to make a company
lose value and short it and sometimes
it's legit
that you're actually finding fraud and
sometimes you're spreading fear and
uncertainty and doubt
ultimately you as a retail investor
which i think a lot of us are here we
own shares in companies some of us play
the market some of us
buy long some of us like to trade daily
you really need to look at the totality
of what's happening and what milestones
are completed
because these are private companies
essentially that are now going public
well what do i do to avoid this as a
private company investor
i will look at the company and i do
diligence and i look at the original
contracts and i talk to the customers
in this case if i was doing my diligence
on this company
we would say show us the contract with e
squared and
who signed the order show okay whose
signature's on the order great we'll
we'll talk to that customer and ask them
why did you order 14 instead of
140 or 4 000. why 14 000. that simple
question
is going to get a really telling answer
and if you can't get that person on the
phone
well then you don't do the investment so
um and this is what i tell my team when
we do diligence
if the if the company takes a long time
to get us the diligence
and there are three four five red flags
and
they can't explain them quickly boy
we're probably going to pass on that
deal
so for people who are in a private
company who are raising money
keep your diligence tight never ever
exaggerate
i talk about this in my book angel where
a company told me they had facebook and
google
as customers and when we asked to see
the contracts they told us they had an
oral agreement when he asked them to
who the people were that they had the
oral agreement with they said the person
at google they had to deal with
they met at a party and they don't
remember their name and i was like okay
you're committing securities fraud
you're literally telling us
that certain things are true getting us
to buy shares
the sec takes this seriously
in business it's important to be
memorable and sending gifts is a classy
way
to create that great memory but gifting
is tough it can take forever
or you can send to the wrong location
and people never get it it's never been
scaled properly until
now snack magic is a stress-free easy
and customizable way to delight
employees or customers
snack magic uses software to help
recipients build their
own snack box gifties can choose from
over 500 snacks and beverages including
diet and allergy friendly
options all you need is the recipient's
email no shipping address is required
you send this link to your employees
they pick in a cart what they want they
could pick drinks they could pick snacks
and put their address in and the box
comes to them and it counts down so if
you give each employee 60
or 160 dollars if you give it to the
weekly or monthly
whatever you want to do you can give it
to current customers for your sas
product
who you want to renew as a thank you or
maybe you're trying to get some sales
prospects to close and you send them
this or
maybe you make a mistake in customer
service and somebody's nix tickets don't
work
and you want to make it up to them like
happened to me so whether you want
to delay just one person or you want to
delight a thousand people
snack magic makes it easy they're in all
cities and
in the united states and then all over
the world many different countries so
you can get 10
off right now if you use the code twist
at snack magic dot com slash twist go
ahead and check out snackmagic.com
twist